foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create amazing actual
relationships open phones here I'm Dave
Ramsey your host Rachel Cruz number one
best-selling author Ramsay personality
and my daughter is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Cody is
in New York to start off this day this
hour hey Cody how are you
hi Dave it's uh great to be on the phone
with you you too finally meet you I've
been watching you for a little while now
well thank you how can we help
um so I had a question
um about I recently put myself
um back a couple baby steps uh by going
and getting myself a truck loan but now
uh A girlfriend of mine of course you
know not married so you know I know
roughly what where I'm already at
thinking you know especially watching
you
um she wants me to finance a car for her
um I was thinking if she comes up with a
large down payment you know I'm in
pretty decent uh Financial shape myself
you know
no I know that is but that's true
so I was um thinking if I could go
through um
if I should Finance the vehicle for her
or not because
um it's a really big deal to her
obviously she has a vehicle now so in my
eyes she doesn't need one I went and got
it inspected for her so I know it's good
for at least another year
um
I'll get your take on it
Cody if you were to guess what we would
say what would your guess be
of course not I mean
I know oh and here's what sucks a month
toward us so you get it paid off I know
so here's the deal is like it is number
one just taking on debt in general is a
risk and then number two when you put
your your name on someone else's debt
that's a massive risk and we have had
even more risks yeah just so many calls
okay so do you want us to help give you
a good argument to give to your
girlfriend is this part of why you
called yeah yeah that would be great you
know you know I've went over the points
of you know interest rates are higher
right now I have my own you know I've
had the conversation with her you know
like can can you wait until I get my
truck paid off I'm expecting to get my
truck paid off I I financed um 30 33
um 33 400 for it
um I've made literally three payments on
it what do you make
I make about a 120 a year what does she
make
uh
uh she's making about 800 a week
you can bring home okay and how long you
all been dating
yeah uh like four months
how old are you two
uh I am sir I just turned 30 and she
just turned 19. okay
uh you just described a sugar daddy
yeah yeah you're not kidding
[Laughter]
um yeah she doesn't make any money she's
19 years old and she wants you to go buy
her a truck
um no a car probably a car
Rachel you're gonna crawl out from under
the desk now
um the uh yeah yeah so you you make a
lot of money she didn't make any so
um
number one I don't know that there's an
explanation for her that's going to
satisfy her
okay yeah because uh she's not gonna be
loving a no of any kind no matter how
logical or sweet or well crafted okay uh
so let's just be prepared for the fact
that she ain't gonna like this okay
number two uh if you were my son who is
um just a tiny bit older than you
um I would knock a noggin on your head
if you did this because a lot of reasons
number one what Rachel said you're gonna
get yourself in a mess number two of
course we teach you not to borrow money
of course we're not going to teach you
to borrow money for for yourself even
after you finally get your truck paid
off because it was a mistake to go in
debt for the truck in the first place
we're gonna stop doing that so that you
can become wealthy making 120 000 a year
okay so we're going to take that off the
table we're just gonna take that there's
no explanation for it Cody we're taking
debt off the table you called us you
knew what we were going to say so but
here's the biggest problem all right
um relationally this feels like it's
going to be a strain if you don't do it
and I will tell you from having coached
um
folks for 30 years that if you do this
you're going to put a bigger strain on
the relationship because you're changing
the tone the flavor of the relationship
from two independent adults seeking a
high quality connection to now one is
dependent upon the other
all right and it changes the it changes
dinner
on me it yeah yeah yeah because you just
and now you're somewhat dependent upon
her because if she doesn't pay the
payment making 800 a week shock
um then you're gonna end up having to
pay the payments shock okay and uh then
there's going to be another strain on
the relationship and so you're going to
do damage
to whatever the quality of this
relationship is it's going to get worse
if you do this yeah so that's the
biggest reason not to do it the second
biggest reason not to do it is there is
nothing no scenario that turns out
positive out of this all the scenarios
are negative and I think too Cody I
would I would be curious on the
relational side how she takes the no
probably reveals a lot about her right
and and the kind of person you want to
be in relationship with and so what
she's really doing here yeah you know
and but if she's willing to learn and
she's like okay so why won't you co-sign
you're like well because of this and
this and this and I want to get out of
debt I want to do you know what I mean
and you may teach her something new
which is great you know I'm not saying
she's like a bad person but y'all's
value systems might be might be very
very different and then the other thing
that would it would happen too if you
co-sign and she loses a job before she
suddenly decides oh I'm gonna go on a
fun girls trip and spend money and oh
sure I just can't make my car payment
this month and you're thinking you just
went on a girls trip and you're not
going to pay your payment and now I'm
stuck with like you're going to start
analyz sizing everything that she buys
and purchases and so like it just yeah
the whole thing it's it's just is so
it's it's very messy so let's be real
clear it won't be co-signing because
there's no Bank in the world going to
sign her up for anything no that's
probably that's probably yeah she's
living below the poverty level so you're
you're gonna own a car
with a car payment and then you're gonna
have to go pick up your car
from your ex-girlfriend when you break
up
this is going to be
and then you're gonna feel terrible if
you broke up with her one day and then
you have to go be like I need my car
back she's like I don't have a car I'm
gonna get to work and now you're
dependent you're still I mean it's just
yeah yeah no good plan but Cody I
appreciate you calling yeah thanks for
for asking yeah I and uh I I sympathize
with where you are and you're you're a
nice guy trying to think about this yes
yes you did call the people who tell
people not to borrow money so that they
can become wealthy and outrageously
generous and has to borrow money period
bad idea number two doing that with
people or four people that you're not
married to bad idea number three when
the person you're doing it for is
completely broken makes no money super
bad idea
so let's just keep adding on to this
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author and my daughter in my opinion
it's never soon too soon to get the
Christmas spirit as a matter of fact if
we just did Christmas year round it'd
suit me fine I love generosity I think
generosity is amazing I love Christmas I
love Christmas traditions all the old
songs in particular and we have an
awesome Christmas tradition we have the
Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway
starts a couple days after Halloween
apparently
Christmas Is Here
starting today you can enter to win one
of our weekly 500 cash prizes or the
five thousand dollar grand prize all the
cool things you can do with that cash
during Christmas time go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
enter every day to increase your chances
of winning no purchase is necessary you
got to be 18
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and right
on time for Christmas the ten dollar
book sale is back if any of our
best-selling books or tools have
impacted your life and you're fired up
well this is your chance to share it for
ten dollars yeah like 10 Christmas gifts
for 100 bucks
you could just go ahead and start
knocking out the list and check it twice
like your Senti there you go you're
fired up share it 10 bucks this will do
it life-changing books like baby steps
millionaires they're putting baby steps
millionaire that's the number one
bestseller I just did it did you say
fancy ten dollars
did you say Santi I said Santi I did all
right making sure well it took me about
10 seconds to process that okay yeah
you're late to the drawing I'm almost
done with the commercial
paycheck to purpose for 10 bucks and
delony's conversation cards for 10 bucks
now that makes sense because they're a
little deck of cards I mean like oh my
gosh all right these are deals people
this is a deal shut up all right shop
our biggest ten dollar sale yet
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping and
new promos all the time use the promo
code Ramsay to save money
today's question comes from Ian in
Florida asking for advice regarding
retirement contributions I'm 27 my wife
is 26 she's a recent stay-at-home mom
she has about 35 000 in a Roth IRA I
have about 40 000 in a Roth IRA and or
in a Roth IRA and 60 000 in a Roth 401k
we both max out our Roth IRAs each year
but I also contribute 10 of my income
and two in a Roth 401k at work about 15
total income going into my retirement
accounts my question is should we be
contributing more in a traditional IRA
in her name unless in my name obviously
the retirement is mostly now going to be
in my name and not hers and I feel
somewhat weird about this even though we
are good Financial Partners what are
your thoughts
uh no I wouldn't feel weird about that
uh if most of it's going into your I
mean as long as you guys are investing
15 of your total income uh I don't
really care where it goes it's just the
importance of putting that money away
for the future so Ian if it leans more
into
your Investments versus hers I mean I'm
fine with that a total of 15 of your
household income
should be going at baby step four not
more it sounds like you're doing more
sounds like you're no it's like there's
a lot of these yeah so like you're doing
15 plus a Roth for your wife it sounds
like if you're going to do a Roth if
you're going to do a an IRA for your
wife you can do that as a spousal IRA
and
um that's fine into good mutual funds
and if you've got good 401K Roth and a
match at your place you can do that but
the total of all of this mix should be
no more than 15 Rachel's right you're
concerned about it being in one name or
the other is Irrelevant in the event of
death
you've got a beneficiary on it and it's
her
it all goes to her in the event of
divorce the judge is going to take half
of it and give it to her
so there's no I mean there's no downside
for it doesn't matter whose name it's in
because she's protected either way so to
speak you know I've heard people say
well you should always you know keep
your finances separate and you're fine
you ought to have your own retirement
account handled in case of divorce well
in case of divorce in any state in the
United States they will take half your
freaking 401k and give it to the other
spouse it's part of the deal it's part
of the property settlement okay so you
just you're not there's it's not
protected uh from that so you can't you
can't do that so it won't work all of
our retirement not all but I mean 96 of
my retirement is in my name because your
mom has been a stay-at-home mom since
Denise was born 30 some odd years ago
almost 40 years ago now yeah and so
uh you know and consequently I've been
every year but when we do a Roth IRA
every year but I load the 401K in my
name too so when you add it all up it's
mostly in my name but um Sharon's not
the least bit worried about it
it's a good woman would not occur to her
to be worried about that she assumes she
could take it from me at any time she
wants and she's correct
oh all right Amy's with us in Dallas Amy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Rachel and Mr Ramsey I'm not sure you
remember me but I called earlier this
year kind of overwhelmed with prosperity
um Rachel we bonded over the craps table
bit but um
oh you're one of those oh okay
you end up liking me at the end of the
goal but I took all of your guys advice
except to increase my lifestyle so I
kind of had we've kind of been having
this like under budget problem and what
we've been doing is just putting all
that money into the market
which I like because it's down right now
but then psychologically I feel like I'm
trying to time it which I also shouldn't
do so I'm kind of like what do I do with
the extra money
now I'm still under budget and I I can't
help it
having extra mileage was a great problem
maybe okay so remind me I'm trying to
remember could you please run for
Congress uh
so you're out of debt both my husband
and myself are Engineers
um I'm 33 he's 32 baby step seven yeah
back then it was 1.7 or 8 million now
it's probably like 1.6 million net worth
but you know who cares way to go you've
killed it well done so what do you do
with the extra money that you have every
month is what you're asking and you feel
we are putting it into the market
because you feel like you're trying to
time the market and you feel like you're
motive you're right and I know I
shouldn't but like I guess I would do
that even if it was up too because yeah
but you've not increased your lifestyle
because I remember talking to you and
saying you guys need to enjoy some of
your money and you haven't yes that's
our problem right
now how much extra um I'm thinking like
it's been like five five thousand a
quarter oh not much
no no I'm not talking to some people but
in your world you're worth two million
dollars you're 32 years old it's it's a
thousand fifteen hundred bucks a month
okay all right yeah yeah and so I don't
know I just it's like do it I don't know
if you're gonna tell me just find
something to buy or do whatever you want
no no I mean I wouldn't go buy something
just to buy it but I do want you guys
because you're both Engineers I know how
you're wired so like I do want you to
enjoy life and so increasing your
lifestyle some I would take some of that
if you haven't yet and yeah increase
your lifestyle by a few percentage
points and throw some of that extra
there and then Amy you know I'm just
thinking like what Winston and I do we
have a money market account that extra
money will go into after we've done
everything if we have any extra it's
okay it goes in here and then we kind of
have a short-term goal so whatever it is
whether it's replacing a car or we have
a big five-year goal of doing a pool one
day at our house we really want to pull
so we're kind of putting money towards
that but we like we're working towards
something
um and so that's always helpful for us
to have that thing that we're working
towards so if you and your husband you
guys have anything that you want to
accomplish or do in the next five years
um but I guess maybe that's part of the
difficult thing I don't know what the
next school should be yeah I mean it's
like okay did you upgrade our house yeah
what I did at your stage was I just
threw the money in I just threw the
money in a mutual fund until it was
enough there to buy some real estate
that I paid cash for it was a simple
goal and so
um and I actually
um I bought a little lake house for
almost no money after I got my first a
couple hundred thousand in there and um
that that little lake house is now gone
and now we have a bigger lake house but
it started a whole trend of us buying
real estate with leftover money I'll
give you something else to do that I
think you really do I think it'll be
good for you after talking to you for a
minute
budget 300 a month for outrageous tips
and random generosity at the gas pump
and I want you to walk up with cash and
look somebody in the eye and blow their
mind do that for three or four months
and then tell me you hate it because you
won't be able to say that it'll blow
your mind three or four hundred bucks
out of your out of your thousand or 1500
just just just you don't do it for the
rest of your life but you probably end
up doing it the rest of your life this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author and my daughter so Rachel I just
got an email at the break that we put
the borrowed future documentary on
YouTube uh just a handful of days ago
about a week ago and there's already had
200 000 people view it awesome so um
once we put it on there and made it free
it was a whole three dollars or
something like that on Amazon Prime but
um yeah it's free on YouTube and uh
while this whole student loan discussion
continues to be a Hot Topic
especially during a political season
this is a good thing to watch because it
will give you the inside
scoop on how nasty the whole student
loan debacle is and you don't want to
miss it it's called borrowed future and
you can just jump on our YouTube page
you'll find it there and you can watch
it for free and watch it with your teens
or send it to any send a link to anybody
that you know that has a team that that
might ever think about going to college
and doing something stupid like going
into student loan debt there's lots of
ways around that and lots of reasons to
avoid it and that way you don't become a
political Pawn in this mess that's out
there Chris is with us Chris is in Fort
Worth Texas hi Chris how are you
hey Rachel and Dave I also watched wild
future and that shook me to my core I
think everybody should see it thank you
my question is about you're welcome my
question is about the investment
strategy and the four kinds of good
growth stock mutual funds International
is The Fourth Kind that spreads our risk
Beyond American soil
uh it appears to have a lower rate of
return no it's worse than that it sucks
uh diversifying into are we sacrificing
return
why do we do that you know I actually
just asked the same question about
um oh probably about 24 months ago
because uh you know what we teach are
time-honored principles
like get out of debt and the borrower
slave to the lender in the Bible and so
we're not going to change on those
things okay we're not going to suddenly
go oh there's a certain kind of you need
to go do this step now we're not going
to do that okay but you know the fort
mutual fund types are something I
dreamed up with other people the guy
that started the show with me was an
investment broker and we dreamed that up
and ran models on it and stuff uh 30
years ago and so it's not a sacred cow
and so I got to looking at it and I'm
looking at my own returns and I'm they
asking the same question you're asking
because this thing I mean it doesn't
just mildly underperform the other three
it sucks you know and so I went to our
uh smartvestor Pro and I said hey help
me run some scenarios out on this
because I'm about to change my advice
after 30 years I mean after 25 years
it's people are going to be shocked
they're going to fall out in the floor
Dave Ramsey changed because he never
changes you know but I never change
because I'm right but if I'm wrong I
need to change so we dug it up dug into
it and I had him run a bunch of
scenarios out and I said okay what if if
I'd didn't have for the last 30 years if
I didn't have international in the mix
if I just did the other three run out
what would have happened and run it out
what if it did it was in there and uh
certainly if you run it out and um
like five year blocks or like certainly
the last 10 years uh you would have over
performed not having it in there
so my advice you know but but the weird
thing is what he did do is he he pulled
up all of the
uh weird times in the economy we're kind
of in one of those right now as a matter
of fact like a bear market and we found
that the international shored up the
others uh because they would dive down
below it and then come back up past it
and the diversification actually did
work to where you ended up
mathematically better off because of
those weird anomaly downturns made up
the difference and uh we ran it out I
mean you can you can get with a good
investment broker like our smart
investor pros and they can run
hypotheticals they're called on the
computer you can put like let's pick
four good mutual funds that are in the
four categories with long track records
and then let's run it with it run it
without it run it in you know for 15
years five years ten years twenty years
40 years let's run it back and forth
back and forth as best we can let's see
what would happen if we hadn't put it in
there have we been making a mistake all
this time which I because I was having
the exact same question you got Chris
it's a really good question is my point
I think but the weird thing was it it
worked out better to have it in there so
I kept it in there but it still kind of
baffles my mind a little bit because it
sucks so bad is it I have a great smart
investor Pro
um can I give a shout out to him on the
air sure
he's checked Buckwalter at my house
Whitaker everybody in four five six and
seven he's the call of this guy but he
showed me the international and it does
coincide with
um what you said I wanted to ask on Eric
because I thought everybody should know
and what your answer was that there are
a couple of years where it just
outperformed crazy and it made up the
difference do you think that might
happen again it does because it's
happening now it may be happening at
this moment but Market cycle and so
you're gonna have these weird anomaly
years in the rhythm of Market cycles of
up and down turns and yeah that so he
found what what I found when you all
talked about it right Chris that that
right that the math actually so it
really it what it did is it was kind of
a cool illustration of the theory that
diversification is that you're safer
and you make more money in the long term
by having different kinds of things
rather than all your money in one thing
and that's really what it illustrates
and it's a beautiful question thanks for
the underhand pitch then Chris you
already knew the answer but yeah very
cool but we and all the other categories
did you guys run that like the
aggressive growth because they weren't
bothering me they were performing at or
above Market but the international is
just like it's just you know that I make
some bad metaphor but yeah it's it's
it'll get me in trouble but the um yeah
no it's it's not it's not happy it's not
as happy a fund I mean and our category
uh but there's a weird thing that some
of these uh it's a foreign market yeah
stock that you're buying and things are
happening in those markets in a Germany
or uh that aren't happening that aren't
happening here at the same time but with
this downturn because it feels more with
inflation all of it it's a it's a global
yeah but a lot of it is global sometimes
you'll have a global upheaval but yet
the international particular
profitability of those particular
companies in that yeah does isn't it has
a it's not exactly inverse to every
negative thing right right but it's
enough that it it just proves up our
theory of diversification there you go
yeah so the Bible does say there is you
know one scripture that deals with this
but it doesn't point out the four mutual
funds it just says in Ecclesiastes
spread your portions to seven yes to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land and you can fill in the blank on
disaster whether it's covet or planes
flying into Towers or uh 2008 bubble
bursts or the Great Depression or
whatever but if you have all your money
in one thing some duper drops the basket
on that thing then you're screwed yeah
and so the diversification is is just a
general biblical concept and you know we
knew in the investment World 30 years
ago when I started doing all this stuff
that that you don't put all your money
in one category because if you did you
would just pick aggressive growth
because it's always got the highest rate
of return right totally but it's
exciting yeah yeah it's really exciting
but it's really exciting going down too
you know feeling it all yeah so you know
you don't take into consideration the
volatility and the offset and the other
stuff so it's a very interesting
question and I uh I appreciate you
bringing it up also to tell folk so we
can say out loud that you know there are
things we don't change around here and
we're not going to change and I saw you
answer a thing on Instagram like you
just give your dad the same advice
because it's right you know it's we
don't you know you don't need to change
it but the uh except for the crap stable
that's fine except for the crab stable
and the Tesla but yeah but other than
that yeah
um
so there has to be some rebellion in the
middle child but the uh um the uh uh but
aside from that the the principles don't
change the processes in your life should
always change
the principle is you need to balance
your checkbook
even if there's an internet
that allows you to do all your Banking
online you still need to reconcile to
balance your checkbook or it may not be
a checkbook anymore
in the old days we got out and you know
they sent us all our checks back in the
mail we would mark them down and then we
would spend all this time with a little
10 key calculator trying to make sure we
hadn't missed a check and weren't out of
reconciliation with the bank weren't out
of balance with uh what we thought we
had versus what we really had and you
still need to do that stuff you still
need to keep track of your dad gum money
uh that doesn't change but how you do it
yeah you still need to be investing and
diversifying but how you do it could
change but in this case it worked out
that it didn't need to change this is
the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
fragile Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author my daughter open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey if you like this show do us a favor
tell people about it share it with a
friend if you got the ability on YouTube
or the podcast to do a share it's easy
you can do it electronically but
certainly just mention it go hey you
need to listen to the show it'll change
your life this information is cool leave
us a review where you can as well and
leave us a five star review we don't
need any one Stars thank you and uh you
can also consider subscribing if you
would at YouTube or on podcast where it
automatically hits your phone
automatically hits your the way you
consume and listen to this stuff um I
was listening I was walking this morning
walk anywhere from a mile to three miles
every morning and I was out there it's
beautiful fall morning and a buddy of
mine stopped talked to me he was driving
by and uh he's like what are you
listening to what podcast you listen to
this morning and so because I've always
got a podcast in my head as I'm walking
and listening to somebody I was actually
listening to Smart money happy hour this
morning oh I really was thank you I
haven't listened to the to today's
episode I need to yeah it was good I was
gonna say George on that one always says
you know when you're going to rate the
podcasts just do as his mom said if you
have nothing nice to say don't say
anything at all so hard to heard him say
that
pretty good thing to steal yeah you guys
went through and we're looking at the uh
I had not heard the phrase fintok yet oh
yeah I almost threw up a little bit in
my mouth when I heard it but um the
financial advice from Tick Tock fintok
hashtag fintok hashtag hashtag yeah and
uh and yet I probably have some on there
you probably got some on there but there
oh okay so and so we tried to spread
hope yes you did yeah and y'all are so
nice because you didn't trash the people
I that's it I was listening to it I was
going to see if I was doing that I've
been no holds bar the guy's an idiot I
mean jeez unbelievable
and trying to make it go anyway it's a
great it's a great it's a great it was
good it was a good show y'all did a good
job with it it's a great episode well
buying whole life for your
three-year-old
I see them they're like just telling you
that's like the motivation behind it
that's just so nice he's a whole life
agent doing an ad with his kid in his
lap that's what he is doing he's had his
baby he sold his baby out because I
really believe though that he believes
that that is the best thing to do don't
you think or do you think
whole life people that know it's a scam
and keep selling it which makes them
Crooks and people that can't do math
it's the only two kinds of people
selling packages you can't do math
because he seemed like a very but he
believes the company line for the 30
minutes that he worked there
and uh 80 of the whole life agents don't
sell for more than one year and they're
out of the business because they wake up
and realize it it's terrible no I agree
I agree I agree I'm just saying they're
just sweet it was just sweet y'all are
nice and you're we're giving you're kind
we're giving Humanity a chance
may not realize how terrible it is but
we're going we're giving you the truth
of how terrible it is I just think I
just think of all the people that might
have followed his advice that's what's
scary I agree I'm with you I don't want
it out there it's wrong but hey I did
see because Tick Tock you know it's a
big platform but there's someone and I
read an article about it that's trying
to get like the US government to ban
Tick Tock in America or something I
don't know
because the Chinese on it yeah and
they're and they're raping everybody's
data yes so I'm like man all the data
even going to is it even going to say I
got access to your phone you gotta have
a conspiracy theory about that oh I
don't have to talk on my phone okay
there you go I won't because conspiracy
theorist right here no I won't I will
not no I don't either but it's for other
reasons all right Evan is with us in
Kansas City hey Evan what's up
hey Dave I got a heck of a mess on my
hands and I could use your advice on how
to tackle it we'll try what's up okay so
uh my mom has pretty well squandered all
her money her whole life about five
years ago she inherited 400 000 from my
grandparents and between my siblings
stealing it and
um her squandering it it's pretty well
all gone and she never has really taken
care of herself her whole life and my
siblings want to have a conversation on
Thanksgiving about putting her in a
nursing home because her health is that
bad and I'll be honest with you Dave I'm
just to the point I don't want to pay
for it I mean she's made a lot of
horrible mistakes in her life I have two
I'm on track to pay off all my debt in
the next six months and I just I'm kind
of wondering how you would best approach
that conversation or that situation
I'm sorry how old is she
ah she's about 62.
ancient
what what's
my age well what's what's her health
condition because you said that she
she's in bad Health what is it like
early Alzheimer's or is it what
no it's it's very overweight I mean she
got so heavy one point her knee started
to hurt and so instead of losing weight
she bought an electric wheelchair so she
didn't have to walk anywhere and she
just it's just it's going downhill okay
pretty fast my sister lives with her now
and it's to the point where she can't
take care of her and it's it's this I
know I've seen this coming I don't know
my siblings have but I have seen this
coming yeah okay is she she is destitute
she has no money
yeah no house no property no money in an
account
well so here's the she does own a site
at a campground and she does own a house
so I do know we could sell that for a
little while but that's only going to
last so long
okay because the house isn't worth
anything I mean we can get maybe 20 000
out of it maybe two or three thousand
out of this campsite that she owns yeah
okay so she doesn't okay so here's the
thing
um what you guys need to study and you
need to do a little study on it before
you get to Thanksgiving is uh there
there's welfare nursing home it's called
Medicaid
and it will not take her house it will
make her sell the campground and apply
that but after that Social Security
basically pays Medicaid pays for nursing
home and she goes to a Medicaid nursing
home it's government funded now
um it's not it's not as
fancy schmancy is if you're paying 80
grand a year to be there you know
okay yeah but uh but but she'll be okay
I mean they'll feed her and take care of
her and
um and if she needs care she can go into
a Medicaid nursing home and
um and it sounds like that none of you
are multi-millionaires
no um I'm probably the most Financial
off
um and the part of the issue too is I
mean we're having this conversation at
Thanksgiving
a few days later uh very soon later I
deployed them to the uh to Europe
okay so you're not going to be involved
in terms of physically you're not going
to be there so yeah and I I can't be in
the discussions I'm not going to be in
the sort of thing well you can be in
discussions unless you're on some kind
of a mission that doesn't allow
communication with your family
right
very yeah okay all right thank you for
your service
um I'm sorry you guys are facing this
because it's a very it puts a knot in
your stomach because on the one hand you
got the hermis behavior and your
siblings misbehavior with her money that
and all that and on the other hand it's
your mom
right and so it doesn't matter how much
she screwed up should tell your mom
and there's a stop happening so um it
does it it breaks your heart in two
because one side is saying this is
ridiculous and the other side is you
know she's your mom and so um I'm sorry
you guys are in this position but I
would just simply tell everybody we're
going to Medicaid just find a Medicaid
nursing home and put her in it it's that
simple if she needs care because none of
you can afford to fund it
yeah do you the question also I would
have if she hasn't had a job in 20 years
would that affect any other social
security medication anything like that
nope she'll still get the Medicaid
okay and but again you need to read up
on what the exceptions are they used to
be you could keep a home uh with value
uh Equity up to 78 000.
um and you can keep a certain amount of
dollars in your checking account and
beyond that they would provide
um I don't know what the numbers are
today I haven't looked it up in a while
but no ancillary things like campgrounds
or whatever so you're going to be
selling that and giving it to them to
the nursing home but that won't even
last a month so it doesn't matter
I mean between you and me Dave I mean
I'm going to argue that the house goes
too I mean if we're that's fine at this
point there's no reason to have it yeah
I don't disagree but I I think you just
go look none of us can afford it and
Medicaid is the option and this is how
we're gonna take care of her and then
you don't have to get in a big oh you
used up all our money you stole all our
money and she misbehaved and she's not
taking care of it you don't have to get
into all that you just take care of her
plug her into that it's the only thing
you can do I'm sorry you're facing it
it's awful this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where Dad is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people who
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Abigail is in
Topeka Kansas hi Abigail how are you
well hello there thank you for taking my
call Dave and Rachel sure what's up
well you both say that that's not a
money problem that's a marriage problem
and I know that's what I have I've been
married 40 years and I'm staying in the
marriage but I'm scared I have no
retirement to speak of we have no
retirement to speak of and we're getting
old
um how old are you guys
he's 69 I'm 62. yeah
and you have
you guys have no retirement
he has uh 40 000 I have 16
000.
are you all still working
yes
um he he's had very consensory
businesses over the years he sold uh his
last one and then quote retired for two
and a half years and now he's back in
the workforce we make plenty of money we
just spend it all
huh and what's his
what's his hesitation of well you're
saying we spend it all so
I'm gonna go with that language is it
mostly him or is it you as well that
you're thinking I I don't have great
money habits either
we don't have Furs and jewels we have
nothing really to show for it we've been
doing a budget for four years after we
did FPU
and yet no matter how much money we
bring in out the door it goes and last
night he said to me
that gazelle intensity is BS I'm not
doing it well we've completely paid off
all the debt well let me just say we did
and then
I did again and again and again
and
what's what's really got me scared right
now is his health is failing and even
though I'm a late bloomer I was a
stay-at-home mom for years and years
um I had the capacity to make a lot of
money with all the
stress I
it's just wildly
like last year with 50 Grand this year
is 175 Grand the year before two years
ago it was 185 so it's back it could be
a low year it could be a high year what
are you not putting anything away what
do you do and now I need a new car what
do you do and he wants to go into debt
for the car what do you do
don't laugh I'm an attorney and I have
my own business but it can fluctuate
wildly oh why would we laugh
it's not funny it's wonderful
congratulations
thank you pretty cool
um and you have the ability to make
really good money some years yeah
uh
I
um
everything we would tell you
um
short of fixing this in the marriage
counselor's office is a poor substitute
and at best a Band-Aid or at worst would
cause more damage to the marriage
um marriage counseling uh I'm I'm
tempted no this guy I mean I get I get
where you are I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm just saying if I tell you to do
something else part of the problem is I
got 20 million people listening it might
give one of them permission to do
something else and I don't want them to
do it
um I want them to I want to get them to
the root of this and to fix it but um
in if you're going to stay married maybe
you need to act like you're divorced
separate account yep
he doesn't have access to your income
anymore
yeah
yeah and you make 195 000 you can go buy
a car pay cash for it a car that fits
you know within your cash budget and you
just operate your little life there and
um
um
it's but I gotta tell you it's not it's
not it's not a good way to live
is that because of her age no it's just
not a good way relationally no I'm
saying you're going to be living in a
house with a roommate now
I know and that's where first person I'm
like I
you know yes because we say that it's
it's more of a marriage issue than a
money issue it's coming out as a money
issue but there's something about him
that isn't willing or doesn't want to be
on the same page with you and be a team
with you for the rest of your marriage
and you guys can still have another 20
years of this life together and so I
would want to get to the root of of of
his
his pushback so much you know what is it
because he he's smart I mean he can look
at numbers and know we don't have money
to retire and is it is it a pride thing
is it a fear thing like what is it in
him that refuses to say I'm gonna I'm
gonna stop spending everything I make
and put it away for the good of of my
future and my wife's future and all of
that like I wanna
I want to know more of what what's going
on in him and all that yeah I agree I I
um I can't believe you said separate
accounts uh well I'm
you know I I said it was 73 caveats but
the uh um uh what I'm saying and I'm
trying to get to why you said that is it
because of her age and she's going to
retire soon and she needs money to live
off of like or is it because most you
know what what needs to happen
is she needs to lay down the thing and
say if we're not going to do this
together we're not going to be together
after 40 years
you know that eventually it's going to
get down to that because her level of
respect for him is going down and down
and down and down and down now she's
being very careful to be very classy but
in between all those words was a lot of
anger and disrespect which I would feel
the same way and most people would yeah
and she's like you know this guy's
baggage and um you know I'm smart enough
I'm an attorney at late in life I became
an attorney and I can go do this and I
don't I don't need this crap that's all
in there and it's not going to get
better if you separate the accounts it's
going to get worse yep
because you're going to watch him over
there in this playing the sewage and
you're over here playing with gold coins
and so
um it's just a problem so I mean Sharon
I've been married 40 years and I can
tell you what would happen at our house
uh we would go and sit with a counselor
and we would try to find common ground
and if she bowed up and said I I
absolutely refuse to be smart I am going
to spend like I'm in Congress and we are
going to be on welfare as we go into our
retirement years because I am prideful
and I will not deal with this and I'm
not going to face this and I'm not going
to discuss it
um then she's going to find her own way
I guess it'd be really sad I hate that
but I I because the alternative is
actually worse yeah
it's actually worse
so um yeah I would put him in a corner
but I mean I'll do it systematically
kindly gently lovingly patiently yep but
I'm gonna put him in a corner and we're
gonna solve this because this ain't
gonna work out yeah I'm not gonna look
across the room at you and hate you 10
years from now I'm not gonna do it this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality and my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if the economy
has you looking over your shoulder these
days well we understand
all of us are kind of giving it the side
eye right now and going uh yuck you
people are messing this up and that's
why we're on the road doing Building
Wealth live events as a matter of fact
night before last we were the sold out
crowd in Sacramento a lot of fun over in
California thank you guys for turning
out for that next week we will be in
Minneapolis and the following week we
will be in San Antonio all sold out
thank you guys are very very much we
appreciate that it's me and Rachel Cruz
George Campbell Dr John deloney and Ken
Coleman uh and so uh guess what we're
adding the spring events to the list
today adding to the spring events list
today uh good stuff going on so we have
already had Indianapolis on February the
16th up for sale and selling very
rapidly thank you same with Austin Texas
on February 23rd and Anaheim on May the
2nd here's a couple of new dates for you
we will be in Nashville doing this event
on January the 12th looking forward to
that and of course saw Lake City on
April the 24th a brand new date as of
today
don't wait to get your passes our spring
Building Wealth live events of uh uh old
dates are already selling out of VIP
level passes generally general admission
is not yet sold out but the VIPs and
platinum VIPs go very very quickly on
all of these and the General Admissions
only 39 dollars and they go quickly as
well all of our fall events were
sellouts thank you very much America we
appreciate it we understand you're
scared and we want to try to give you
some answers and people responded well
in California
do it yeah it was fun it was a great a
great crowd yeah they were nice people
and we were really enjoyed being with
you guys a couple nights ago so uh
tickets start as low as 39 for the
Building Wealth live events again
Nashville Indianapolis Austin Texas Salt
Lake City and Anaheim if you want to
come tickets are on sale now for all of
those two of those I just announced at
the second it's the first time anybody
knew about it all at ramseysolutions.com
events
ramseysolutions.com
events and get your tickets before they
are gone we've also announced the smart
conference a very special edition a
two-day smart conference Friday night
all day Saturday in the new Ramsey Event
Center April 14th and 15th
and that will be the inaugural event
with commemorative passes and all kinds
of special things we're doing in the
Ramsey Event Center only holds 2 400
people the typical smart conference is
six to eight thousand people so that
will be a very early sellout again if
you don't have your tickets to that
you'll want to get that that's of course
here in Nashville as well or Franklin
Tennessee just south of Nashville all
right Henry's with us in Madison
Wisconsin hi Henry welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave
long time listener thanks for taking my
call certainly sir how can we help
I'm in a bit of a bit I'm in a big mess
and I just wanted to get your advice on
it okay so
um I took FCU about 12 years ago I I
know the system I have every dollar Plus
um
I've been engaged to my fiance for about
seven years the only reason that we
haven't gotten married although I
haven't gotten married is I can't afford
to give her her day that she deserves
she wants to wait for that day
um and my concern is is that uh she just
lost her job
due to medical reasons and we lost her
insurance
she has Cobra but it's 800 a month
there's just absolutely no way that I
can get I can put that 800 line item in
the budget
is it in this situation is it ever
appropriate to take a hardship withdraw
from traditional retirement products so
that you have health insurance
uh do you have health insurance at your
work
I I I'm eligible for health insurance at
my work but I'm a massively serious
connected veteran so the VA takes care
of all my health care
okay so are you taking about Let's
Pretend a theoretical thing happened and
this was your wife
could you not go to your work and get
spousal insurance through your work
cheaper than eight hundred dollars
I could good but you're getting married
today congratulations confirm on wanting
her big day congratulations toughies
sorry welcome to grown-up girl land
all right seven freaking years
dude that's weird
I understand don't you think it's weird
I think it is a bit to be honest yeah
yeah
five years ago
yeah so you know now she don't have a
choice
her Health's gone and she gets to be
married so that she can get insurance
and we'll call that the special day
and um you guys can have a celebration
because you don't have an 800 a month
bill
um seriously this is the um
results of this decision that this
weird poor decision to drag something
out seven years has put you guys in this
situation so you've got to fix it I mean
it's the it's the fastest bright way to
fix this on so many levels on so many if
Henry if that's real I mean yeah it's
one of those things like is she who you
want to spend the rest of your life with
I'm assuming so because it's been seven
years but is there a hesitation in you
not wanting to fully commit as well
we've been going through a rough patch
and if we were married I would want to
be going to marital counseling but
um foreign
I want to spend the rest of my life with
okay so if you know that for sure you're
gonna go through hardships and marriage
right or wrong so if she is it and
eventually that's where it's going to
lead then yes I'm with Dave it's like go
get married go y'all y'all are playing
like this you basically are married
without actually the legal documents so
we we have shared finances everything
we've been playing house for five years
yeah so go yeah yeah so go go get
married and then you guys as a married
couple are gonna realize oh wow we got
to go figure out this money stuff and
get on the same page or you say all
right
sweetie you gotta go get another job and
figure out your health insurance because
no you don't need to take hardship
withdrawal from retirement or she
doesn't either what's wrong with her
health no she would do it um she would
do it diabetes diabetes and morbid
obesity
um she's on we're not sure if she's able
to go back to work at this point
okay
I mean if she's the one Henry
you gotta you gotta yeah
so
um I'm nervous though that the big I
don't know yeah the big day of the
wedding it's like
okay let me let me um take one step back
not 10 steps back but one step back
um
how old are you guys
I'm 34 and she's 31. okay all right
do you have kids together
uh no no kidding okay
okay
um her
health
is
you you guys need to sit down and see a
can you need to spend more than 800 on a
counselor
and you guys need to sit down with a
counselor and you need to dig into
what's going on with her
and uh the special day stuff
um and how is that tied is there any
connection between that and her health
issues
um because I I I'm not a counselor but
I'm smelling a rat and so
um I I would want to get to the bottom
of all of that before I rush off and get
married
um because if she's not gonna and you
get you guys aren't gonna deal with your
issues as a couple and she's not gonna
deal with her issues that are underlying
in all of this then
um
that that's causing these this weird
that's causing this weird situation
there's something she's she's hurting
somewhere and there's something that's
causing this I don't know what that
stuff is I don't have Dr Delaney here to
help me but there's something causing
all this stuff and you don't need to get
married until you figure out what that
is and we're working on it and then you
can figure out the health insurance
thing but the if everything else was
Glory but it of course it's not Glory
because we're seven years sitting around
waiting painter get off the ladder so um
yeah you need to get to why
these things are going on and if you can
deal with them why then get married and
that'll help her with her health
insurance but no you don't need to have
combined finances you're not married
we don't recommend that
I recommend combined finances for
married couples because it puts you in
this weird situation where you're buying
health insurance for someone that's your
roommate this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you you that's why you need to
get in touch with Churchill Mortgage to
make sure you do this right these guys
are awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions is uh
quite a few folks you can jump by
anytime you'd like we broadcast the show
live every day from one to four Central
and it is free to watch we don't
guarantee it to be entertaining but it
is free and so you're welcome to come at
any point and do that and also folks uh
schedule with our team to do their debt
free screams in person live here on the
official debt free stage there with us
Sean and Nilda hi guys how are you
pretty good how are you wonderful thank
you for having us we're honored to have
you where do you live
Orlando Florida very cool and how much
debt have you paid off a hundred and
fourteen thousand wow how long did that
take 12 months whoa and your range of
income during that time uh we started at
220 000 and then
um we're projected to be around 300 by
the end of the year wow what do y'all do
I'm a registered nurse hero amen I do
applications for a medical imaging
company okay all right so both of you
are working a lot yes yeah a lot a lot
to get this incoming one yeah you can
you you and you work all you want and as
little as you want right now I mean it's
crazy out there so congratulations okay
what kind of debt was the 114 000 our
house you paid off
she was 29 at the time I'm 31. okay and
what's the house worth uh just check the
little homebot thing we got from Deidre
at Churchill it's 370. 370. and you're
30 years old and it's paid for you guys
are so weird
I love it never been accused of being
normal I love it I'm so proud of you how
fun how long have you been married
a year about a year yeah oh my gosh so
you get married get a house and pay it
off boom
I had kind of bought the house a while
ago it's kind of a long story but I had
bought the house a while ago and we
finally got married and just got gazelle
with it okay all right well tell us the
story how did you what was the plan here
well as part of the story too is she
paid off six figures of Consumer Debt on
her own before we got married so that's
not even included in these figures Super
impressive
um but a co-worker introduced me to the
baby steps in like 2014 and uh it made
sense to me I had been raised to live
below my means and had been shown an
amortization schedule in high school and
so all these things kind of made sense
and I was like oh yeah that tracks well
but um I wasn't factoring in that it's
80 behavior and so I had all this
knowledge but I was not acting on it I
was doing daveish for the longest time
and uh just making her mad talking about
it all the time but not doing it myself
so how could I how could I lead that way
so um anyways I I uh what do you wanna
yeah well he introduced me to you back
when we met in 2014 and I was like ah no
like We'll always have debt like that's
just a normal thing and and he was like
no like just follow the plans follow the
plans so when I graduated nursing school
I started
following it but I was doing Dave ish
because I got a car after I graduated
nursing school
and then around 2019 I read your book
Rachel love your life not theirs yeah
and that one changed my life and then I
became gazelle intense I paid off my car
I paid off my student loans and then uh
wow yeah she's a rock star for sure
that's amazing that's amazing yeah yeah
that's that's hard work that's hard work
so then when you guys came together you
had no debt going into the marriage a
year ago
at the house the house and then you guys
said okay let's pay off the mortgage and
and you went for it yeah we said about
it it was it was time for me to because
it was all intense you know because I've
been watching her do it and so I was
ready and um it just was all
serendipitous I guess yeah in January of
this year we um only lived off of one
income so 100 of my income because I was
able to work overtime 100 of my income
was going to the mortgage so we were
paying about like fifteen thousand
dollars a month since January
yeah it was amazing slam slam slam I
love it you guys are amazing
congratulations thank you has it even
settled in that you're like 30 years old
and you don't have any payments hey at
all house or anything no how whacked
that is I don't think so no it hasn't
you're gonna be so rich
fifteen thousand dollars a month
we're gonna do with all this money now I
mean Max retirement number one
what's your first big thing you want to
do with money now that you're out
um I don't know we're still living way
below our means that will always be the
case yeah but um we have some trips
planned and yeah we've had we spent
three weeks in Montana for our honeymoon
we waited a year after we got married to
go on our honeymoon so we can save for
it and you know pay for it all in cash
and then um
but I think the first we already started
investing for our next house
um hopefully that'll be our short-term
goal and pay for it full in cash and we
maxed out yeah imagine retirement we
have new Charities so yeah yeah
how much have you already got saved in
your retirement in this day oh upwards
of around three hundred okay all right
so you're all you're so you're 31 and
you got six hundred and fifty thousand
seven hundred thousand dollars in net
worth already yeah yeah you're gonna be
gonna be millionaires and like by
Christmas oh my God it's pretty
impressive yeah it's amazing that's
weird that's just so cool I'm so proud
of y'all thank you thank you so much so
so both sets of parents came to cheer
you on it's really wonderful to bring
them off and we're up in Hendersonville
for the week well they got to be really
proud there's no chance you're moving
into their basement exactly I mean this
is great yeah yeah did you all have
friends along the way that were curious
about your journey like what you were
doing were there cheerleaders along the
way were there people that were like
y'all are nuts yeah most of my friends
were like you don't have to work so hard
like it's fine just just stop working so
much overtime you're gonna burn yourself
out and I was like no I have to do this
I have to do it I would call him in the
bathroom at work crying because I was
just like just so burnt out but then he
was just like you don't have to work so
hard I was like I do I have this goal
and I was like I want to do it by 30.
yeah you won't burn out you were just
tired I was tired that's what it was
yeah but you don't get burned out when
you gotta go yeah that's true burning
house when you're just spinning that's
true for nothing but when you when
you're going towards something you just
get tired yeah I knew there was a goal
at the end so that's why I kept doing it
but
um yeah we had the amortization schedule
on the fridge and we would be Crossing
it out with different colors each month
and it was always a goal to smack as
many lines as we could and you had to
gamify it like you say all the time yeah
exactly yeah wow no discipline that's
cool congratulations
what lit you up Yeah we actually have
um that book and then I had lent it out
to somebody and I just was like you know
what it changed my life so you can have
it so I gave it to her and we actually
do and I remember from the book you had
talked about
um you had a couch that you were
embarrassed of and
I was feeling the same way because we
had a couch I didn't really like and I'm
just like you know what people don't
really think about that so using a place
that's it yeah so after that I paid off
my student loans and then I paid off my
car and my credit cards and all that
stuff so it's amazing well done you guys
now you can get a couch
I guess we did do that yeah I love it
hey we've got a copy of Total Money
Makeover for you baby steps millionaires
because you're going to be there in a
heartbeat and celebrate that with you as
well and a one-year membership to
Financial Peace University and a new
copy of love your life it's not theirs
we're gonna throw them all in just to
say we're proud of you and
congratulations very very well done you
two thank you all right quickly what's
the secret to getting out of debt
well of course number one you have to do
the budget you have to follow the plan
exactly don't do davish come on if
you're doing Davis right now I'm talking
to you do the plan if you do the plan
you'll get the results you say that all
the time and I would say thirdly Embrace
The Core Concepts of capitalism that's
self-ownership and private property
these things are attainable in today's
world even here and now and despite of
all the government intervention in your
life you can still do it and I would say
you owe to yourself to do it and
posterity as well wow amen amen
hallelujah
Sean and Nilda Orlando Florida 114
000 paid off in 12 months house and
everything at 30 years old count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Applause]
well in case you thought Millennials and
gen Z law lost their minds we get the
best ones around here I know this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Rachel's my
co-host today Jared is with us in
Minneapolis so we'll be up there next
week to see you guys hey Jared how are
you
good how are you doing better than I
deserve how can we help
hey I got a question about a I got a
small business
um I got two trucks and um it seems like
every time I get caught up
um I got another big bill that I can't
cover
so then I'd put it on a credit card and
I just kind of feel like I'm stuck in a
loop
okay
um what kind of business are you in
the towing company
say again I'm salvage cars towing Towing
okay so you have two tow trucks yep okay
yep so you just
um like most people maybe even like me
got up uh and just decided
I'm in business today
um well I've been working on the
business for like 12 years working is
different than running it
and so now you now tote operating a tow
truck is no longer your job your job now
is running a business and you're really
good at operating a tow truck and now
you're having to learn how to run a
business is that fair
yep yeah okay so what kind of big bills
are coming up
unexpected
I got a it's a higher mileage truck so I
just had a turbo come go out on me it's
about 8 900 with the intercooler
and I'm hoping to put about two grand
down but I don't have enough to cover
the rest of the bill
[Music]
okay
who's driving the other truck
um it's just me they got um
you have two trucks and you just shoot
yes park it till you make the money
with the other truck
okay what's the other bills that have
come up unexpectedly
um it's just bigger repairs and they
just seem like you got like six or eight
a year it seems like okay
I would think that that's not really
unexpected that's predictable
okay I think you're gonna have X number
of thousands of dollars average per
month some months none some months
double
of repairs because you've got a fleet of
trucks two trucks on the road and um
Towing stuff's hard on trucks
okay so you're gonna have repairs it's
part of your business model
okay I guess what I'm afraid of is if a
motor goes you know it's like 30 grand
to get it rebuilt do I get rid of the
truck or do I just just expect it to be
coming up and save up for it exactly
I don't think it's if a motor goes I
think it's when it goes
yep it's gonna go it's part of your
business you're going to wear out these
vehicles you're going to have small
repairs medium repairs and huge repairs
and Replacements these are part of your
business model and setting money aside
to keep all of that running like paying
the rent for a restaurant or paying a
worker that works there you've got to
set it aside out of here you've been
just making the money taking it all home
and maybe paying your taxes
yeah well I pay myself out of it too I
pay myself about 40 Grand a year that's
what I mean you're taking all the money
home there's no money laying down the
office
yes so you're just making the money and
taking it home you're treating it like
you have no expenses hardly other than
Fuel and insurance you're paying some of
that but
um yeah so uh
my guess is you're probably not charging
enough
okay they are set rates for the most
part which isn't kind of sucks dude set
rates by who
um they're mostly Insurance cars oh okay
insurance companies setting the rate
yes sometimes you bet on them but for
the most part they're set okay
all right I'd be looking at my business
model because fuel's gone up repairs
have gone up everything's gone up and if
the insurance rate set rate doesn't go
up that might not be the business I want
to be in I may want to be in a a
non-insurance towing business or
something I don't know but you got to be
looking at all of that all the time
bottom line is though you need to be
running a profit loss statement I'd have
you sit down go to ramseysolutions.com
click on tax ELP and find someone that's
in the bookkeeping and accounting
business in your area that we recommend
have them start to help you build an
accounting system it's really not rocket
science it sounds intimidating but it's
not it's what you've got coming in minus
money set aside for repairs minus money
set aside for fuel minus money set aside
for
insurance
and help you look at the pricing and
seeing you know can I afford to do this
you might be losing money on every tow
if if uh repair costs and insurance
costs and fuel costs have gone up so
much that by the time you you go over
there you're losing money every time
that could happen in the world we live
in today with this inflationary market
and this Fuel and Diesel's gone nuts too
so and factoring in the repairs like if
you do all of that and do your budget
for the month to see you know the actual
repairs because
um
you don't want to live behind the eight
ball which is where you are you're
always behind you're you're always
waiting on the next thing to happen
instead of planning for it to happen and
so uh Jared in the real estate business
uh back in the day when I was a a young
guy they taught us if you own an
apartment complex to say okay uh the the
roof has five years of life left on it
before it starts leaking and so I need
to figure out what a roof costs and I
need to put one-fifth of the roof cost
away for the next five years to replace
the roof plan to replace the roof and we
called those a sinking fund uh that's
what's called in that world but in in
your sense you need a sinking fund to
replace trucks and or do big repairs to
trucks and you need a budget line item
for minor repairs to trucks and for a
budget line item for fuel and a budget
line item for these things and you need
to put all the stuff together and then
that helps you calculate light what each
trip costs and whether or not it makes
sense to do some of these trips and and
it helps you save up and fix this one
turbo right here as fast as you can
because you're going to put a big old
line item in there and um you know
you're gonna you're gonna work extra
you're gonna do everything you can to
get extra money coming in to cover this
right now but no I'm not going to tell
you to go into debt to do that I'm gonna
Park that truck and run the other truck
until I can do it it's what I would do
if I own the business and uh it's how
I've run this business too I started it
on a card table in my living room and
we've never borrowed a dime all the way
out hang on I'm going to send you a copy
of our book entree leadership which will
help you run your business it's what we
teach how we teach small business people
to run their business you're doing a
good job you're doing better than you
think you're doing but you've got to get
around in front of this because this is
causing a ton of stress for you that is
that doesn't have to be there doesn't
have to be there but um
so folks what happens is what happened
with Jared and what I was accusing him
of not in a derogatory way but just
reading his male is a lot of people
become good at a trade
I'm a good plumber I'm a good heating
and air guy I'm a good Carpenter I'm
good at cooking
I'm good at being a chef I'm good at
whatever and then they open a business
I'm a good real estate agent and then
they open a business I'm going to own a
real estate company with agents working
for me I'm going to open a heating and
air company with heating and air techs
working for me and I'm going to have
trucks I'm going to open a towing
company and you become an accidental
leader
an accidental entrepreneur
but what we always the mistake all of us
make and I I've made the mistake too
even inside of the Ramsey business I've
made the mistake just because someone's
good at a certain discipline or a
certain thing that does not necessarily
mean they're good at leading a business
to do that thing business leadership and
business entrepreneurship is a different
skill set than working on heat and air
or than working or then doing computer
programming or then whatever so if I've
got a computer programmer that's an
excellent computer programmer it doesn't
necessarily mean they may be the best in
the building but it doesn't necessarily
mean they're a leader yeah of that area
because leadership is a different skill
set than computer programming and so
anytime you're in the small business
setting one of the moves you make is
from practitioner to owner
you move from your hands doing the work
to also your brain has to be controlling
the numbers around your hands doing the
work and the people that use their hands
doing the work and so you got to get up
on top of it and my friend Michael
Gerber who wrote the book e-myth which
is a wonderful book on this subject says
to work on your business not just in
your business yeah that's his phrase and
it is an absolutely fabulous phrase and
it's a good way to look at this stuff
entree leadership will help you with all
of that
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books our thanks to Austin Ben
Zach Andrew and James in the booth the
booth dudes I'm Dave Ramsey and we'll be
back
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show we're dead as Dom
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create real amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
joining us America guys we are hearing
from you from time to time that you're
dealing with banks or credit card
companies or car dealers or whoever and
you're saying well I'm going to close my
credit card or no I'm not going to
borrow money to buy this car or whatever
and they give you some kind of yeah yeah
yeah and you go well I'm on the ram MZ
plan I'm in financial peace and then
some of you are telling us that you are
getting a
scripted response to the fact that you
brought us up or you're getting a
some kind of weird something happening
we want to hear some of these stories
we're kind of curious what's really
going on so if that's anything like that
has happened to you recently email us
and tell us a story right now uh we want
to hear from you ask at
ramsesolutions.com use our ask email and
that'll go straight to the production
team and they'll be able to tell us
what's going on there so ask at
ramsesolutions.com and tell us your
story if you've had some kind of
I don't know scripted or weird response
to saying I'm not doing that stuff
because I'm doing Ramsey whatever that
stuff is or maybe you're maybe you're
getting rid of a whole life policy I
don't know and you hear you hear weird
stuff because so we hear some really
wacky stuff out there from time to time
and we're just kind of wondering how
true it really is and because obviously
they're not going to say that to me
uh unless if they actually know who I am
you know so I did have that happen one
time I went into an electronic store and
was trying to buy something the guy said
you need the extended warranty and I
said no and he goes well Dave Ramsey
gets them and I went I thought he knew
who I was I started laughing I thought
he was joking with me and I'm like well
no Dave Ramsey doesn't get them and he's
like oh yeah he does he started arguing
with me until I handed him my driver's
license and then he set a curse word and
so um but yeah
zombie stuff like that's just fun y'all
you gotta know that's fun so we want to
hear from you ask at
ramsaysolutions.com William is with us
Williams in Louisville Kentucky hi
William how are you
I'm doing good Dave how are you doing
better than I deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call um and Rachel
too uh my question is uh we're looking
for for guidance on how much we should
spend on our on our next home uh we're
debt free and we've got a paid off house
right now and I'm saving up for a next
and bigger home and I'm just looking as
as for recommendations on how much we
should spend on that as like maybe as a
percentage of our net worth or where
you're at on guidance you know going
into that bigger home category so you're
paying cash
for the upgrade we're we're saving cash
with the upgrade but we've got a this
house right now could probably net 350.
and we're looking at homes in the you
know five to 750 range and uh we've got
probably another 100 saved up for that
one but we're not you know we're not to
where we can pay cash for the next one
yet okay are you planning to wait until
you do or you're going to take out a
small mortgage and then pay it off
well originally I was I wanted to wait
and then you know now uh we had uh we
just had our fifth uh kid here two
months ago and we're you know more than
outgrowing the house that we're in and I
think we're all ready for for something
new and
and you know I could I could save 25 to
40
000 for a year towards a new one but
it's going to be you know eight ten
years before I think I could get into
you know into
having it having all the cash flow to
answer your question yes I'd probably go
get a loan first yeah what's your
household in the Gap in between this
about 150 000. okay okay
well yeah are you I mean the way I would
look at it is okay what can I get for
the house how much cash do I have
putting all those numbers together and
then saying you know if it's that
mortgage payment you can go back to that
25 of your take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed rate that's kind of our formula
for
for a house in Durham but you're putting
down a massive massive payment down
payment
um because of everything you're going to
have from your from your current home
and what you have saved
um so yeah I would I would look at those
numbers and then I would run out to a
time frame to say man we want to be if
we can do this and we can be debt free
again in
four years or whatever whatever it may
be so that you can pay it down quickly
uh I would factor that timeline in as
well William and and talk to your wife
how many kids do you guys have five
we just had we just had ourselves we
just had your fifth I'm sorry okay
yeah so um what do you do for a living
uh I work in uh engineering and uh
construction good for you okay
the um and you ask what percentage of
your net worth uh when you've got a uh a
net worth of under a million
um you know your house is going to be
the larger percentage of your net worth
typically
when you especially when you work
towards a paid for house okay and so
um you know like we had a young couple
last hour doing their debt free scream
their house is 60 percent of their 70 of
their net worth uh they just paid off
their house and so um that's not gonna
be unusual you wouldn't want that high
the higher your net worth the smaller
the percentage would go to your house
if you have a hundred million dollar net
worth you wouldn't want 60 percent to
your house you know that'd be weird
you see what I'm saying so even a 10
million even a 10 million dollar net
worth you wouldn't but in your first
million of net worth
um you know it's going to be the larger
share it's going to be 50 North of 50
probably uh wouldn't be that unusual but
the good news is the house isn't going
to go up and you're going to be once
you've gotten that house paid off you're
going to be chunking into retirement and
so by the time you get to 2 million
it'll be 30 percent
or something like that and uh so you
know you're the natural tendency is
going to be your other Investments are
growing faster than the house because
you're adding to those after you get the
house paid off and so um yeah that as
far as your net worth question goes it
sounds like everything you're doing is
very safe and you're fine just put it on
a shorter term as you possibly can
maximum of 15 years maximum of 25 of
your take-home pay but I think you're
going to be well below the 15 year you
might want to do the full 25 and then
even more beyond that uh but I'd set the
payment up at 25 on a shorter term as
that will allow given the given the
price you buy with the down payment you
have and if that means you do an
eight-year loan fine if it means you're
doing a six year loan fine that's fine
put tenure put on that that's fine just
put it out there 25 and then throw extra
above that on it but your actual
commitment monthly don't let that be any
higher than 15. partner than 25 of your
take-home thing so you're doing good man
you're doing good you're thinking about
it you're way ahead you're not normal
you're already weird congratulations
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
was made for you the never quitting
non-stopping gazelle intents
with gazelle you can say goodbye to
monthly fees and experience a seamless
integration with every dollar so no
matter how or where you spend you are
always in control and since gazelle is
FDIC insured you don't have to worry if
your money is safe
gazelle the debit card that helps you
spend and save the Ramsay way
[Music]
[Music]
well a lot of you are planning a move
sometime soon that's awesome we're
excited for you but I gotta be real
whether you're moving across country
across town you could be facing some
sky-high home prices rising interest
rates the challenge of finding an
experienced Pro you can trust when it
comes to something as important as
buying a home you can't just use some
friend's cousin who got their license
last month
and a simple Google search can really be
that's kind of a really dangerous
uh you should be able to find High
Caliber Real Estate Pros that you can
rely on whether you're removing whether
you're moving from Florida or to Alaska
if you're buying your first home
somewhere in between and you can find
these Pros we've vetted thousands of
real estate agents around the country
and you can trust Ramsay trusted
every one of them to do the job well
from start to finish we spend a lot of
money a lot of time making sure these
are high producing agents that are the
best of the best they're part of our
endorsed local provider program and
they're Ramsey trusted they've earned
our seal of approval they prioritize you
over just getting a check they're truly
experts in the cities that they serve
and they do serve Ramsay listeners
you want the best real estate agent to
sell your house not just some goober you
met at church not just your Aunt Sally
who got her license going to have her
feelings hurt don't list your house for
those people it's silly it's your
largest asset a monkey can sell a house
but that doesn't mean one should so you
need to go to ramseysolutions.com
agent get the best agent possible for
your real estate transaction
ramseysolutions.com slash agent Marcy is
in Cape Cod hey Marcy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Rachel hi Dave how are you better
than we deserve what's up in your world
um I'm calling because full disclosure
before I started listening to your
program I leased an 86 000 vehicle
um
I know I was like a Range Rover Sport
um
it is sweet however I ended up pert or I
ended up leasing the diesel version
um so the cost of diesel has gone up
exponentially in the last few years and
oh and try being on an island and
getting diesel yeah so yeah it's not the
best um so we are now at the point where
I have saved up enough to pay off my
lease it's coming up at the end of the
lease I owe forty five thousand dollars
um I have the cash to be able to pay
that out but knowing that the cost of
deal is so high and eventually diesel
vehicles may not be
um as popular as they once wore I'm
concerned about like maintaining
maintaining it and that kind of thing
should I one buy out the vehicle and
then try to private sale it right now
KBB is listing it around 52-59
um should I just turn it in and uh you
know pay the fees for my over mileage or
um should I I'm not sure what to do here
okay so let's pretend you can get 55 for
it and you can buy it for 45. that's
what you're telling me
yeah we buy it
even if we turn around satellite we buy
it
okay it's my 10 grand on it right
what what is your what would your Gap be
so if I buy it for 45 and I can only
sell it for 48 would you still make that
you know that that failed well if you're
selling it to a dealer you might only
get 48.
but I mean I think you know do a little
bit more research get comfortable that
um that the cars are actually moving and
then you can sell it the hot the more
expensive the car the harder to sell
just like anything
right easier to sell 20 000 Carnage or
40. there's more buyers okay so that
that's going to be the thing and just
start you know poke around out there see
what how long some of these things have
been on the market talk to the Range
Rover dealer and ask them how fast their
inventories are moving
um they may have somebody in their back
pocket a buddy of mine had a Jag the
other day and the dealer knew he had it
and just called him out of the blue I
mean it's a friend of his was the dealer
but he said hey have you still got that
car and he said yeah he goes I can sell
it for you right now and he goes I'll
take a thousand bucks quick because I
got a guy stand here that wants it and
he just made a quick thousand the dealer
did and and sold the dadgum car ten
thousand dollars more and he paid for it
you know so it was but it was just a
weird deal so I would make a few phone
calls see what you can get into because
anytime you can buy something that you
really if you truly believe it's worth
55 and you can buy for 45 I would
so the radio I went to two locally just
in the last two weeks and the highest
they offered me was 49 for it
um dealer offered 249. the deal yes oh
I'm buying this
okay that means that means that means if
you sit on it for a month and a half or
two months and you can't move it in the
50s you can take it over the dealer and
make four four grand
okay
all right great yeah I'm buying it and
and then you know you don't have to keep
it just because you bought it that's but
you also don't have to panic sell it
either
right okay because you got the money I
mean if you wait on Spring to sell it
it's okay
and drive I won't drive it this winter I
don't know
okay thank you so much you know it's uh
it's a great car
it is I love and I every time I get in
I'm like am I ready to let it go
for it and I have it and I probably will
never be able to get another one again
now oh yeah I would rather invest yeah
you can but you know at this point I'm
like you know I um you could drive it a
year and still make a and still break
even maybe
yeah okay you know just enjoy it and it
depends on I mean what's your household
income
um it's myself only and I make 145.
okay and uh you have other debt
I don't nope no I'm I would pay it off
and keep it and drive it a little while
just enjoy it a little bit okay and then
let's sell it and if you make a couple
thousand great if you if it costs you a
thousand when you sell it so what
um but I I might enjoy it get give
yourself you know September or something
give yourself a date
and then just kind of keep poking around
and if somebody walks in offers you 59
sell the stupid thing and get you
something else right but I would just
kind of mess with it with a open hand
you follow me rather than a sense of
desperation like or a sense of regret or
a
um with that kind of money even selling
it for close to 50 I'm like you can buy
a great car even another Range Rover you
know a used right and that was my fault
like I could even buy like a newer via
like a new vehicle off the lot somewhere
for probably 25 and still like have the
warranty and have all the safety and the
security and like the maintenance free
for a few years and I think either way I
I do when you're right I'm in a good
situation but it's more of like so I
just turn it in and cut my losses and so
you guys have helped me I knew I called
the Dream Team on the right day
bless your heart you're too kind I
appreciate it so a couple rules on cars
uh they've calmed back down now
the used cars are no longer going up
and value you remember that moment you
guys will be able to look back in 20
years ago I remember back in all 20
20 21 when the cars went up in value you
know you'll be telling your grandkids
these stories right and
um
uh because it was It Happened One time
in history that's the and you were here
when it happened so uh used cars go down
in value Like a Rock that's where Chevy
got that like a rock okay so found on
the road is Ford is found on the road
depreciated f o r d there you go so um
hello this is this is real and you don't
keep a lot of money tied up in
depreciating things although I'm a car
guy and I love cars I want you to have a
nice car I just don't want your nice car
to have you so we always say no more
than half of your annual income tied up
and things that go down in value hers
doesn't violate that she's at about a
third
and she's paid for it no debt no debt no
debt started out wrong but got there
yeah so she's not violating any of the
guidelines
and the guidelines are there that we
came up with to cause you to build
wealth they're not cause you to live in
a cave collect Clinton only come out of
triple Coop on Thursday they're there to
cause you to build wealth and when you
have a fifty seven thousand dollar car
and you make forty two thousand you are
going to be broke your whole life
because of stupid things going down in
value
and you've got money going and things
that goes the wrong way rather than the
right way it's a math thing it's not a
Dave and Rachel thing it's a math thing
that's what you're facing out there this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Ben and Angela are with us hey
guys how are you hello Dave welcome
where do you guys live we are from
Kennewick Washington whoa it's a bit of
a trip yeah that's the same site of the
state
you know what most of Washington is
saying there's a few spots though that
offset it yeah so a lot of states have
that disease nowadays yes welcome good
to have you guys how much debt have you
paid off so 436
959 dollars
how long did that take about six years
one month wow and your range of income
during that six years in one month we
started at about 1 40 and took a quick
dip for when the Lord blessed me with a
job loss and then uh bumped her all the
way up to a little over 300. what do you
all do for a living I'm a registered
nurse of course and I help people get
mortgages that are 15-year fixed rates
very good new mortgages for a living
very good so I'm going to guess the high
amount 437 and six years maybe you paid
off your house we did I love
those were weird for years but now we
officially are
it's been declared on National radio yes
oh man a mortgage broker with a paid for
house that's so crazy I love it way to
go
congratulations y'all how does it feel
to have no payments
um you know it feels really good uh
knowing that's one less stress in our
life but uh we still live below our
means and we have goals but uh we're not
certain what we're going to spend money
on here forward
like okay what's the next goal but uh
yeah we are very thankful
six years of focus and and now we're
like wow what do we do with with all
this and so we started our next thing
fund we have so many things that we want
to do we couldn't decide so we just
started piling it up in in every dollar
under our next thing fund and I'm sure
we'll figure it out pretty quick so I
like that that's so fun you guys so you
have kids we have four okay what are
their ages uh 27 is Kylie Jacob is 25.
Hannah is 22 and Abby is 17. okay so
most in their 20s and what are they what
do they think of mom and dad uh you know
uh they've been our greatest supporters
through all of this and um I think it
was our goal all along to make sure our
kids
knew what that that Journey was like and
hopefully they became smart with their
money as well so wow very good you guys
are great examples yeah okay thank you
good modeling good modeling Rachel he
says Morris caught than taught yeah very
good so what starts you guys on this
journey six years ago doing this Ramsay
stuff uh so you know April tax time we
sat down and we had our probably our
biggest tax bill we'd ever seen
and we were sitting chatting and we're
like we also made more than we had ever
made in our working careers uh and we're
like wow how do we make so much money
owe so much money to the IRS and we felt
like and we were still living paycheck
to paycheck yeah we were one expense
away from a disaster I think that's how
we could sum it up wow yeah
and how long ago was that was that six
years that was exactly six years one
month yeah we I had heard of Dave you
know prior to that and and uh you know
some of it sounded pretty cool but I
thought I was smarter so you know a
mortgage guy so uh you know but you know
we just we'd had our you know I had it
moment
um and uh and we had also had a
situation connected with us after that I
had a co-worker actually that had uh
turned me on to you I read the book and
and listened to the podcast quite a bit
and we chatted about it you know
probably four or five years earlier than
that and we kind of did I don't know
what you call it Dave ish but we did
Dave a little bit
but uh once we had that you know I had a
moment it was it was all game on it was
just you know
amazing you guys congratulations he
decides we're gonna do this stuff Angela
what'd you say
I hope we're ever going to dig out
dig out but we started and I think what
kept us going in the driving force was
paying off the small debts and seeing
them go away and so it just kept us in
that momentum and uh we knew at that
point um that we'd get there wasn't easy
a lot of struggles along the way but we
made it and so we're very thankful for
that wow so what was all the other debt
part of it was the mortgage I guess a
big chunk of it yeah so we had two cars
in an RV for 61 six credit cards at 39
000 a big honking uh 78 000 student loan
that was mine the IRS debt that we
chatted about 401k loan and wow about
190 for the snowball and then it took us
about three and a half years for that
and then we had about a five or six year
plan on the mortgage but the last two
years have been super good for for my
business and so
um we uh we accelerated yeah and and now
we're sitting you know with no mortgage
payment and my businesses
extremely slow so and I would probably
be freaking out right about now and
thinking about you know what the future
would uh would bring for us but with no
mortgage you know I can don't have to
worry about it yeah yeah we talk about a
lot on uh Dr John zaloni talks about it
too that even when you own debt
psychologically like your mind knows
it's not safe because someone else has
control over a part of your life and
there is this deep sense of Peace when
no one has a say over your life you know
you truly are being able to control that
did you guys feel that I know I'm sure
with the Consumer Debt when that 190 was
gone at the Consumer Debt and then did
you feel it again with the mortgage
when you paid it off I I'd say so
absolutely I mean we had refinanced the
house and done so many home equity loans
that I'm I swear our mortgage probably
contained a pizza from college or
something like that some shoes from
Sears you know when they were still
around so you know I I've been in debt
since I was 18 years old you know when I
bought my first stereo for in college
wow I had a little little Mom Pop store
where you had to go in and pay cash for
your payment once a month you know so
wow
um so it's just so it's an ultimate
feeling for you to feel like have you
never experienced it I mean since your
team yeah yeah wow you ever go back
never never that's obvious yeah not a
chance yeah not once you've done what
you guys have done no this is impressive
well done thank you so much thank you
what do you guys tell people the key to
getting out of debt-ish
um we have uh a saying it's the three
C's communication commitment and
compromise and it's really the same as
keys to yeah being married for 25 years
we celebrated our anniversary three days
after we paid off our mortgage so wow
that was a killer celebration
communication the constant the budget
meetings that we had we'd never done
anything like that and it really just
opened up a ton commitment you know
commitment to each other commitment to
the plan you know just you're just you
know committing to it and there's a
whole lot of compromise you know when it
comes to these different things either
wanting to spend money or not wanting to
spend money different priorities
especially after we hit baby step uh
four five and six figuring out you know
how how fast to go after that uh a
mortgage and and still live so yeah this
was the perfect time for you guys in the
mortgage business because it's tough out
there it is absolutely perfect timing
for y'all to be free congratulations so
oh well done I think hey we got a copy
of Total Money Makeover for you in the
live and give bundle you can give that
away and help somebody get started the
baby steps millionaires book which is
the latest number one and that's the
next chapter in your story for sure and
of course the Financial Peace University
one year membership and again you can go
through it give it away however you want
to do with this stuff it's our gift to
you to say thank you for making the trip
here and to say congratulations we're
proud of you thank you so much well done
you guys very well done Ben and Angela
from the state of Washington they did it
house and everything 437
000 paid off in six years and one month
making 140 to 300. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
I love it I love it I love it
so fun way to go guys this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
scripture of the day Lamentations 3
22-23 the steadfast of the Lord
steadfast love of the Lord never ceases
his mercies never come to an end
they are new every morning
great is your faithfulness
Max Lucado says God meets daily needs
daily not weekly or annually he will
give you what you need when it is needed
yeah Chuck's one doll says God is never
late and seldom early that's true
I love that I'll get the opportunity to
speak for my friend Max Lucado Cato over
in uh over in San Antonio at Oak Hills
in a couple of weeks I guess it'll be a
week from this Sunday so if you don't
have church plans and you're in the San
Antonio area we're going to go in a day
early before our San Antonio events and
things begin and get to speak there he's
um been a friend a long time and he is
quite a wonderful human being so I'm
honored to get to do that Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Joe's in
Jacksonville Florida hi Joe how are you
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve what's up
I really need your advice but I told my
wife I did not want to call and get the
public Dave Ramsey Smackdown because I
know I've been stupid but I am a uh step
six
repeat offender because I'm a real
estate addict and every time we do our
quiet debt-free screen I managed to go
out and do stupid again and buy another
real rental real estate property
but the question I have is we have a
mortgage I want to eliminate on step six
again
and how much or how do we best wisely
calculate our emergency fund how deep
can I go we have the ability to pay it
off
but the emergency fund for our personal
income
is one question but then I guess the
real question is for the rental
portfolio how much of a capital reserve
do we need
yeah
good for you well your personal is three
to six months of expenses
um on a business and that's what a
rental portfolio is it's a business you
would have what we call retained
earnings
and um you know retained earnings would
go for emergencies uh repairs like for
instance the heating and air goes out or
something like that and what also uh you
would also build and and calculate your
retained earnings if you're doing it
well uh for replacement of large items
like say you've got a roof uh that's
going to need to be replaced in five
years then you want to be setting aside
a fifth of that roof each year so that
it doesn't sneak up on you you know and
so you we've got a you know we've got a
apartment complex that the parking lot
is going to have to be redone
um and you know that's a a hundred
thousand dollar expense or whatever it
is right and uh we got three years to do
that though so we're going to put 33 000
aside for three years you know that kind
of a thing so you would systematically
build into your major repairs to keep
you from having uh you know something
quote unquote sneak up on you that
shouldn't really sneak up on you uh and
then the second thing you would hold is
just retained earnings for the totally
unexpected uh but how many houses have
you gotten now
we have uh 19 and
um about 20
23 different units within that yeah have
you got a pre how long you been doing
this
about 20 years you know I had a career
you probably got a pretty good set of
books that you you could probably look
back and say
you know here you know average per house
or average per ten houses or something
uh here's what my unexpected repairs are
water heaters and heat and air
um you know whatever else and you know
you've got replacement carpet
replacement paint replacement on
turnover that's standard tenant stuff
right
um not every time you turn them over but
occasion every every two or three times
you turn them over you're gonna have to
go through and hit that inside pretty
hard we do anyway uh and so on you're
probably used to doing all that I would
say your P L's if you look back through
them would inform
your retained earnings pretty accurately
uh and in combination with that I would
look forward and say what are known
Replacements and repairs that are large
that I've got coming in the next five to
ten years three to ten years and you
know or whatever and let's add that in
there too and somewhere in there is
going to give you a real Common Sense
number on the retained earnings
consistent experience has been about 50
of the gross revenue goes to manage and
retain the business and then we cash
flow about 50 yeah that sounds that
doesn't sound unusual
um so if we if we cancel it depend on
the age of the properties that that you
know if it's a newer property it
shouldn't be that high but um you know
if these are 10 year old 15 year old
properties you probably are seeing that
because you're heating an air starter
should we um keep retaining a full
Year's worth of expenses in reserve then
no it's like six six months
okay you know because you've not you've
not had any cash flow you're managing
your cash already
um you know you're joking around about
you continue to go back into debt that's
a different issue but you're already
managing your cash you've been doing
this too long you got too many
properties if you were doing it poorly
it would already knocked you off the
saddle
yeah I did I want to knock out this last
mortgage I just didn't know how
aggressive I could be with my reserves
well I mean obviously it's kind of like
your personal if you take it down to a
thousand dollars and you pay off your
house heat and air go out the next day
you know so you don't you don't invite
Murphy to the party
so let's just you know let's give it a
little little wiggle room here and not
go too too aggressive but also you don't
need a year and a half's worth of cash
sitting there while you got a mortgage
on you that you can reach over and knock
out with with a few months of that
reserve and but it's like any other
business you can plan out your known
you you get a rhythm of the emergencies
once you've got enough volume like
you've got if you had two houses it's
harder to do but when you got 20 and 23
units you can you can start to get some
averages and you've been doing it a
while and you'll get you'll get pretty
accurate on it
so real estate for me is it's a
fascinating topic I feel like even right
now in our world not just with the
housing prices being up but this is more
I mean I feel like more than ever
hearing people trying to get in to real
estate investing and it being part of
their world I mean it's it feels like
it's everywhere and obviously uh you
know Joe's been doing this for a long
time but do you feel like there's been a
research like a surge of that too versus
10 years ago yeah there was a really
last spring we talked about it a lot
there was a real move and you could feel
it in social media and you could feel it
with Gen Z there was this move of get
rich quick real estate pop back up which
kind of was like making real estate cool
again yeah so talk talk you know talk to
everyone about the wisest way to do it
because we teach cash but a lot of
people are like that seems that's
impossible there's no way I could get in
not important just gotta have the cash
it's not impossible at all you got to
wait till you have the cash and it's uh
so what it must do is to buy that first
property if you're buying houses for
example and let's say you're gonna buy
200 000 rental property which is not
that unusual in a lot of cities some of
your cities it that's not possible but
just call it that and you go okay I'm
Gonna Save 40 Grand a year for five
years it takes a little while yeah but
the first one when you get the first one
then you've got the cash flow off of
that and you got no payments
and so you could throw that at this
savings for the next one and by the time
you've got three or four uh pretty
quickly you can buy a house a year off
of the income from the houses you know
uh that kind of a thing so it snowballs
in a good way that way the snowball
rolls over and over and that's how we
did it right we first bought houses
um and then 2008 hit and I was sitting
on a bunch of cash
and we got into a bunch of commercial at
pennies at 15 cents on the dollar it was
ridiculous so
but the weird thing is if you'll be
patient get yourself in a cash position
you'll find deals and you'll find the
market slows and there's a moment in
time where you can jump in I've never
I've been in real estate business 30
plus years in one way or another and
I've never seen anything as good as that
2000 how it was it was wonderful for
buying for buying yeah because we were
buying a Pennies on the dollar and I
don't know that I'll ever see it again
but I made a lot of money that year two
years really that puts this hour in the
books thanks to Rachel Cruz my co-host
Austin Ben Zach Andrew and James in the
booth of Booth boots I'm Dave Ramsey
your host will be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]